we're talking about Batman as a cyborg
I'm not but hero Gotham deserves what's
the problem here's a scene from my calf
only kill transhumanist perspective a
really common way of thinking about the
different stages of possible
civilizations is the Kardashev scale so
a Kardashev level one civilization has
managed to harness the energy potential
of its home planet we're not there yet
but we're sort of halfway halfway there
right that I can see how we could get to
relatively easily but at stage 2 is
where you managed to harness the energy
of your local star so how would a
civilization go about doing that how
would we do it well we have already
started in our cells we have some
satellites orbiting the Sun with solar
panels we could imagine adding more and
more solar panels to space and
eventually discovering entire Sun you
have an orbiting sphere of orbiting
panels this is called the Dyson Sphere
of the Freeman Dyson physicist who
suggested that we should look for them a
science of advanced civilizations in
outer space so you would harvest some
kind of body that's close to the star so
in our case Mercury I guess is the
nearest body I'm kind of hungry for
Mercury I would put in some robots on
the surface they have solar panels
there's a lot of sunlight on Mercury
they mined the material if they make
more solar panels more robots and keep
on doing this and it turns out that
after a few decades
what started as a few robots by now of
course the vocabulary entire surface the
robots are getting in the way for each
other so there are some logistical
problems that need to be solved but
basically takes about 40 years of
exponential growth to total it is
assembled Mercury and with Mercury
provide enough
I don't know how thick you just solar
panel would be so if we want the kind of
normality solar panel you might want
some other planet Venus might be in
trouble but you can also do things that
are much lighter so one elegant solution
is to use really really thin aluminium
foil if it's fin enough the light
pressure of the Sun will exactly
counterbalance gravity so it will just
hang there
it doesn't even orbit now you can use
these the panels you tilton slide it to
focus sunlight onto some blackboard if
that gets very hot and when you connect
that to something on the outside the
cooling element and now we have a lot of
heat flowing through and this way you
can get a lot of a loop in fact you
could do this out of iron and steam and
do a steampunk Dyson super steam Dyson
Sphere that I can't picture but I want
to exist very much yeah it would be
pretty awesome and it might very well be
but really advanced civilizations once
we deal did the first Tyson sphere so as
we're dead serious about it but now
we're starting to the artistic ones my
family once yeah yeah the meme dyson
sphere's right at the same time I can
imagine you could really focus that
light - yeah now you have it notice 10
to the 26 watts of power and maybe you
use it to power a laser for example
sharks with frickin laser beams attached
to their heads well of course the
ultimate version of a kid the frying
ants with the magnifying glass might be
focusing that laser on some remote
planet which is not good to be good for
the planet
so interstellar warfare you could do
that but it's actually surprising a
crack before interstellar warfare and
which is probably very good news
basically if you want to kind of attack
somebody you also need to know where to
focus about them so a planet is an easy
time but suppose now people are running
away in a spaceship randomly in your
course they're light-years away so you
clean a little thing in and you can try
sweeping around your laser but space is
big yeah so this is actually pretty good
news and that can hide really well as
pets
thanks for watching folks if you enjoyed
this then make sure you click that
subscribe button below because well you
wouldn't want to miss out on any future
videos now would you